appelée ravi de vous retrouver sur
public sénat et merci à vous si vous
nous rejoignez dans un instant nous
allons prendre la direction de
l'hémicycle pour suivre la suite d'un
débat consacré aujourd'hui aux questions
de politique étrangère c'est un débat
qui est organisée en présence de michèle
alliot marie la ministre qui focalise
les critiques depuis ses propos tenus la
semaine dernière à l'assemblée nationale
la ministre au plus fort des
manifestations en tunisie avait proposé
une coopération policière
en début de séance les sénateurs
communistes ont réclamé sa démission
elle va donc répondre à leurs rappels au
règlement
nous prenons donc tout de suite est la
direction de l'hémicycle où c'est le
sénateur ump à jacques blanc qui
s'expriment bonne science à tous l'euro
n'est pas à l'analyse des attitudes des
uns et des autres excusez moi
chacun sait bien ce qui s'est passé et
chacun doit bien vouloir aujourd'hui que
notre pays permettent que ce peuple
tunisien ami de la france puissent
bénéficier de toutes les libertés
s'organiser comme ils ont tant dans le
respect de la démocratie c'est cela
notre mission et moi je veux voir dans
ce débat la capacité pour notre
assemblée d'apporter une contribution de
même que le président du sénat l'a fait
lorsque j'avais le privilège de
l'accompagner
nous étions ensemble en turquie le
gouvernement à ses positions l'assemblée
l'assemblée la haute assemblée a aussi
dans le respect des positions des uns et
des autres la capacité
de dire et je crois d'ailleurs que nous
devrions revenir à la base même de cette
ambition quand vous dites que le
président de la république n'a pas c'est
pas vrai je redis je ne retiendrais
jeunes à retiendrai qu'une aide est très
forte et je limiterai mon propos à
l'union pour la méditerranée reprenez
c'est le propos alors bien sûr bien sûr
que ce grand projet cette ambition très
forte ne peut pas déboucher
immédiatement sur des résultats
tangibles
est ce que c'est la faute à la france si
le problème il serait palestine n'est
pas encore réglé enfin mes chers
collègues chacun et tous les
gouvernements français quels qu'ils
soient de droite ou de gauche
bah ils ont pas pu quels que soient leur
volonté modifier un certain nombre de
cours des choses même si il ya une
volonté de faciliter la venue de la paix
soyons honnêtes les socialistes n'ont
pas été meilleurs enfin quand même et et
au moment où il ya eu une chute de bear
du mur de berlin et la réunification
allemande
on n'a pas on a non j'ai pas dit que
c'était la faute
je dis mes chers collègues que l'union
pour la méditerranée nous nous devons
nous devons au contraire affirmé
plus que jamais une détermination pour
apporter une contribution au
développement économique nécessaire pour
répondre à la jeunesse de la tunisie ou
de l'ensemble de la méditerranée
oui à l'union pour le maghreb en cher
collègue m'a fait chacun sait bien
qu'aujourd'hui entre l'algérie le maroc
la tunisie c'était pas évident et
l'autre volonté et notre mission c'est
de favoriser ce mouvement moi je crois
profondément à l'union pour la
méditerranée et je pense que nous devons
y apporter une contribution forte que ce
soit en soutenant le gouvernement et
madame la ministre d'état que ce soit
aussi par des coopérations sous étatique
j'ai l'honneur d'avoir contribué un peu
ce que le comité des régions d'europe
met en place l arle m c'est à dire une
association
les régions et les collectivités pour le
développement de la méditerranée à
l'assemblée de la méditerranée nous
portons des messages
j'ai le privilège d'être à porter sur
l'eau c'est une question de paix ou de
guerre demain donc ne réglons pas des
petits contes qui n'intéresse personne
mais ayant une volonté et une ambition
celle de permettre que la france qui est
sans doute le pays aujourd'hui dans le
monde qui porte avait le plus de
conviction et le plus de force
un message pour la méditerranée merci
merci mon cher collègue
la parole est à madame michèle alliot
marie ministre d'état ministre des
affaires étrangères et européennes
madame la présidente monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs je voudrais tout d'abord salué
l'initiative prise par le sénat à sous
l'impulsion que d'une président de rohan
d'organiser ce débat sur les questions
de politique étrangère les interventions
que ont montré à la fois l'intérêt que
chacun porte à ces sujets est également
ont traduit la complexité des enjeux de
la politique internationale
malheureusement qu'il y a peu de temps
que ma tante may tandis pendant lequel
je peux répondre je vais essayer de
répondre à l'essentiel des questions
posées en souhaitant que effectivement
qu'une autre fois le débat puisse être
un peu plus long ce que je veux dire
c'est que la nôtre politique
internationale doit s'articuler ce sera
comme ça que je représenterai les choses
autour d'une part de l'urgence des
crises de la cohérence de nos
engagements et de la mise en oeuvre de
nos ambitions pour l'avenir
en ce qui concerne les crises bien
entendu elle dicte nos urgences est
d'abord la côte d'ivoire nous allons
nous espérons nous encourageons une
issue pacifique et négociée de la crise
en privilégiant une solution africaine
et si possible ivoirienne de la crise
ceci dit la situation est complexe il
est indispensable de maintenir la
pression diplomatique avec l'ensemble
des acteurs pour essayer de peser sur
monsieur gbagbo
la france ne fait pas obstacle à la
préparation d'une option militaire
africaine
mais comme l'a dit le président de rohan
nous la considérons comme le recours
ultime et nous préférons que privilégier
des sanctions individuelles et
économique
recompter les bulletins ne serait pas
une solution parce que trop de temps
s'est écoulé depuis l'élection et aucune
garantie n'existe recommencer l'élection
serait évidemment à effet est évidemment
à éviter puisque dans l'ambiance de
tension et de violence qui existe
actuellement
ce serait
risque majeur il ya un certain nombre
d'options intéressantes qui se sont fait
jour et il faudrait espérons qu'avec
l'aide des pays africains et des chefs
d'état africains nous réussissions à les
faire prévaloir deuxième crise c'est
celle de nos otages les uns et les
autres vous avez souligné le caractère
dramatique de cette prise d'otages et il
sort tragique de nos compatriotes au
niger
face au terrorisme au sahel notre
stratégie repose sur une véritable
coopération avec les pays sahéliens
parce que ce sont les premières victimes
du terrorisme
monsieur ministre bockel l'a bien
souligné mais bien entendu des
concertations également de lieu avec
notamment les pays d'afrique du nord les
plus concernés je pense à l'algérie à la
libye au maroc à la mauritanie trois
axes en fait lit de notre coopération
d'abord essayer de renforcer des
capacités de sécurité des états
concernés ensuite essayé de développer
ces pays de façon à faire disparaître en
quelque sorte le terreau favorable au
terrorisme liées notamment aux
difficultés des populations
enfin que protéger bien entendu nos
ressortissants et nos emprises en
coopération avec les autorités d'accueil
je crois que tous ceux qui sont exprimés
monsieur gautier mais est bien entendu
le président de rohan et d'autres encore
ont souligné l'importance de cette
action
et il est vrai que ceux ci accompagne
notre politique je ne peux pas être
d'accord avec monsieur berthou quand il
dit que notre politique est
inconsistante et que la chine prendrait
seul position dans ces pays n'ont en
réalité la chine vous l'avez très bien
dit d'ailleurs est uniquement intéressé
par les ressources de ces pays mais la
façon dont elle les considère est de
plus en plus perçue par les pays qui se
tournent vers nous et qui se tournent
également vers l'europe car nous devons
travailler en liaison avec les
organisations africaines mais également
en associant au maximum
l'europe la troisième crise très
actuelle c'est la crise de la tunisie
alors je voudrais prendre juste quelques
instants pour répondre à madame de
messine mais elle s'est éloignée sur mes
propos à l'occasion des questions
d'actualité la semaine dernière à
l'assemblée nationale j'ai répondu à
deux questions à l'assemblée et je crois
que mes propos étaient claires s'ils ont
été mal compris je le regrette car je
crois que au contraire il visait à dire
ma sensibilité aux souffrances du peuple
tunisien alors même que plusieurs
personnes avaient été tuées par la
police au cours des manifestations
je suis d'ailleurs scandalisé que
certains aient pu et il ya eu aussi des
tendances cet après-midi sciemment
déformer mes propos en les coupant en
les sortant de leur contexte
voir en disant des contre vérités pour
créer une politique politicienne qui n'a
pas lieu d'être et surtout dans cette
période
je crois que il faut rappeler j'ai
rappelé une chose c'est que je déplorais
l' usage disproportionné de la force
j'ai dû dire les usage excessif de la
force
parce que comme tout le monde comme
chacune et chacun d'entre vous je pense
j'ai été bouleversé par des tirs à
balles réelles qui ont fait des morts
parmi les manifestants et de nombreux
morts et parmi eux nous savons aussi
qu'il y à un professeur franco tunisien
et un photographe franco-allemand est ce
que j'ai dit et vous le savez bien c'est
qu'on peut gérer des manifestations même
violente sans pour autant faire usage
d'armes sans ouvrir le feu sans faire
des morts c'est ce que nous faisons en
france depuis plus de 20 ans y compris
dans des situations extrêmement
difficiles et c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'ai dit effectivement que nous
étions prêts pour l'avenir dans le cadre
de formations à aider les forces de
l'ordre tunisiennes à
permettre à la fois l'expression des
manifestations parce que c'est une
expression de liberté et en même temps
garantir la sécurité des manifestants
alors effectivement il est
inenvisageable et je tiens à le dire
puisque madame de messine a évoqué sa il
est inenvisageable que la france prêté
un concours direct aux forces de l'ordre
d'un autre pays c'est contraire à nos
principes c'est contraire à nos lois
je ne vais pas ancien ministre de la
défense ancien ministre de l'intérieur
et ancien ministre de la justice
préconiser des solutions qui sont
contraires à nos lois je les connais les
lois j'aimerais que chacun les connaître
autant alors aujourd'hui monsieur le
président de rouen vous avez évoqué les
voies nombreuses qui explique à
posteriori la crise tunisienne
je vous remercie de l'avoir fait comme
je remercie le sénateur del picchia de
l'avoir souligné aussi et je vous
remercie d'avoir dénoncé ceux qui
prédisaient le passé je voudrais
simplement rappeler à monsieur berthou
de dap monsieur jospin qui en 1997
accueil monsieur ben ali à matignon et
fait l'éloge effectivement de la
situation je voudrais rappeler beaucoup
plus récemment monsieur strauss kahn qui
en 2008 a fait à tunis les loges
effectivement de la réussite du pays et
d'ailleurs reçu une haute décoration des
mains de monsieur ben ali alors je crois
je crois que il ne sert à rien de
vouloir développer des polémiques
je crois que en réalité ce qui compte
aujourd'hui dans ces moments décisifs
pour l'avenir de la tunisie c'est que la
france montre qu'elle se tient aux côtés
du peuple tunisien
nous voulons dans toute la mesure du
possible et d un peuple ami sans pour
autant interférer jacques blanc a raison
en la matière aujourd'hui je vais
simplement vous faire un point la
situation sécuritaire
et contrastée en tunisie est à la fois
une reprise du travail une reprise des
approvisionnements et en même temps
demeurent des pillages et des règlements
de compte le paysage politique lui même
émouvant puisque il y a une composition
d'un gouvernement d'union nationale et
pour autant aujourd'hui il y a eu des
missions de certains des ministres de ce
gouvernement
ce gouvernement va devoir rétablir
l'ordre public convaincre de sa
crédibilité préparer surtout les
élections car l'aspiration des tunisiens
à plus de démocratie et à plus de
liberté ne pourra être satisfaite que si
des élections libres sont organisées
elle sera satisfaite également monsieur
pozzo di borgo vous avez raison si nous
savons mettre en place ce qui permettra
le développement et la réponse aux
aspirations économiques et sociales des
tunisiens et de ce point de vue l'union
pour le maghreb et pour chacun des pays
concernés
une voix qui doit effectivement se
développer et se consolider mais les
engagements de la france mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs s'inscrivent
aussi dans la durée dans la durée
notamment à l'égard de l'union
européenne qui est aujourd'hui j'ai eu
l'occasion déjà de le dire
la seule réponse possible à la crise
économique et également aux défis de la
mondialisation
notre première priorité va donc à la
réponse globale que l'union européenne
doit apporter à la crise avec un
véritable volée de convergence
convergence en matière sociale en
matière fiscale de réduction des écarts
de compétitivité ce sera l'objet des
prochains conseils européens
mais l'union européenne doit également
s'affirmer comme un acteur global et une
puissance politique dans la
mondialisation monsieur del picchia et
pour développer notre influence nous
devons à la fois nous asseoir nous
appuyer plus exactement sur les nouveaux
acteurs stable de l'union européenne la
présidence et et les nouveaux outils du
traité de lisbonne
nous devons également développer la
défense européenne
notre engagement en la matière est
intacte
elle n'a pas été amoindrie mais au
contraire renforcé par le retour de la
france dans le commandement intégré de
l'otan
nous devons donc que nous attacher à une
réelle relance de la défense européenne
autour de cette coopération
et pour que cet objectif soit atteint
nous avons besoin de tous les
partenaires
vous avez monsieur de rend
particulièrement évoqué la situation au
moyen-orient
je pars demain faire effectivement une
tournée dans les principaux pays
concernés
il est évident que l'union européenne
doit contribuer elles aussi aux
solutions de paix il y a eu des
tentatives américaines comme je les dis
aux représentants américaine américain
qui est venu me voir il faut désormais
ouvrir
effectivement et à l'union européenne et
à des pays arabes modérés les actions
qui sont menées en faveur de la paix
sinon nous n'y arriverons pas de la même
façon l'action de la france doit
s'appuyer sur la création de l'union
pour la méditerranée messieurs del
picchia blanc et photos des borgo l'ont
rappelé l'union pour la méditerranée ça
demeure une priorité oui c'est vrai
qu'il y a des difficultés compte tenu de
la situation entre israël et la
palestine
mais comme l'a souligné jean marie
bockel elle n'a rien perdu de son
utilité et nous voyons d'ailleurs un
certain nombre de choses qui aujourd'hui
passe par le recentrage de l'union pour
la méditerranée sur des sujets concrets
sur des projets concrets ainsi la mise
en place opérationnelle du secrétariat
de l'union pour la méditerranée à
barcelone l'adoption du programme de
travail
l'adoption d'un budget pour 2011
constituent des signaux positifs
il faut le secrétariat a commencé ses
travaux notamment sur l'eau la recherche
l'enseignement supérieur nous pouvons
continuer dans le domaine de la
protection civile et des énergies
renouvelables
le partenariat avec lacets avec la
russie monsieur peur dit banco peut
également nous permettre de constituer
un ensemble peut-être pas un pôle
intégrer un ensemble nous permettant de
peser dans le monde
l'année croisée franco-russe a été un
succès qui doit être approfondie en
français en afghanistan et le pakistan
monsieur gautier permettez-moi et
monsieur de ronds permettez-moi d'abord
de vous indiquer que je suis
naturellement à la disposition du
président et plus généralement du sénat
pour répondre à vos interrogations
il serait difficile aujourd'hui et
compte tenu du temps qui m'est imparti
de répondre sur tous ces points
un débat peut effectivement avoir lieu
je souhaite qu'ils s'organisent
je vais pas vous dire qu'il a à être
suivi d'un vote je crois que ce qui est
important aujourd'hui c'est de voir
quelle est la démarche
une démarche qui consiste à transférer
au fur et à mesure que cela est possible
l'ensemble b que pouvoir ou au
gouvernement afghan la situation du
pakistan s'est considérablement
détériorée depuis quatre ans ce contexte
doit nous amener à entreprendre une
réflexion sur les moyens à soutenir les
institutions démocratiques dans ce pays
et à les renforcer en afrique nous avons
parlé du terrorisme il ya
malheureusement si la lutte contre la
piraterie somalienne
de ce point de vue l'opération navale
atlante lancé en 2008 sur notre
initiative a permis que se réduisent le
nombre d actions réussies
pour autant les actions se multiplient
et s'étendent
il faut donc effectivement agir et
notamment faire en sorte que l'impunité
des pirates ne nuisent pas à la
crédibilité de nos actions c'est la
raison pour laquelle monsieur lang a été
chargé d'une mission pour faire des
propositions notamment en matière
judiciaire
mais bien entendu notre politique en
afrique va bien au delà monsieur vertou
des problème de la piraterie
elle s'inscrit dans des lignes qui se
marque par un soutien aux organisations
régionales
ça c'est quelque chose qui est en phase
avec notre temps et non pas des actions
passées qui reposait sur notre
conception de nos rapports
c'est la réforme du dialogue entre les
deux camps
non c'est l'adaptation de notre
dispositif de défense c'est la mise en
oeuvre de coopération
multidimensionnelle monsieur d'euros
j'ai bien noté votre demande de débat
sur la ratification des quatre accords
déjà passés
elle est parfaitement que légitime se
sont d'ailleurs cinq accords qu'ils ont
déjà été signés puisque se rajoute celui
du commun des comores nous sommes en
train de finaliser ce avec le sénégal et
djibouti
on pourra donc les voir ensemble à
défaut de pouvoir voir celui avec la
côte d'ivoire qui aujourd'hui n'est
guère envisageable
monsieur ibrahim les comores sont est
effectivement aujourd'hui entré dans une
nouvelle phase la france sans savoir
aucun commentaire à faire sur les
personnes félicite les candidats
vainqueurs la prise de fonction marque
l'achèvement d'un processus de
transition démocratique
ce que nous souhaitons c'est que ce soit
aussi l'occasion que d'un partenariat
accru entre la france et les comores
entre mayotte et les autres villes de
l'architecte de l'archipel en ce qui
concerne l'auteur présumé du viol d'une
magistrate à mayotte les auteurs
antiques ont été identifiés go grâce au
prélèvement adn
les trois criminels sont aujourd'hui
arrêté grâce à l'effort de notre poste
hanovre moroni de notre ambassadeur et
de l'adjoint de sécurité intérieure le
juge d'instruction s'est rendu pour la
cinquième fois aux comores nous n'avons
plus qu'à maintenant voir avec la
désignation de la juridiction de
jugement
la demande d'extradition à madagascar
depuis le début la france s'emploie à
promouvoir une sortie de crise pacifique
et durable
nous souhaitons aujourd'hui la fin
rapide de la période actuelle de
transition et je pense qu'il ya une
approche réaliste qui est de plus en
plus partagée par les uns et des autres
en ce qui concerne les droits de l'homme
vous le savez depuis l acompte
l'annoncent la condamnation de madame
sakineh
la france avec ses partenaires européens
appellent sans relâche et avec fermeté à
sa libération
nous sommes également très préoccupé de
la situation des proches de madame
sakineh nos ambitions en fin d
sin à long terme les lignes force de
notre politique madame domicile a évoqué
la nécessité d'une politique d'
influence de la france je suis d'accord
avec elle non je ne suis plus c'est
quand elle pense que la france est un
petit pays économique c'est vraiment
nier une réalité qui est celle de la
place de nos entreprises dans l'échelle
des grandes entreprises mondiales
ce que je veux défendre de toute façon
c'est une politique d' influence qui
combine tous les facteurs les facteurs
économiques culturels linguistiques les
savoir-faire éducatif
cette politique d'ailleurs et globale
d'un autre point de vue c'est à dire
qu'elle doit mobiliser cela a été a
évoqué tous les acteurs à côté de l'état
de particulièrement du quai d'orsay
les acteurs publics et privés les
collectivités territoriales les
entreprises et naturellement les
parlementaires madame goubé je souhaite
effectivement pouvoir davantage associer
les sénateurs à mes déplacements et à la
réflexion et j'ai proposé au président
de la commission
la collaboration de diplomates à la
commission des affaires étrangères ce
qui est une façon effectivement de biens
échangés cette politique d' influence
des sites naturellement un ministère
moderniser c'est ce à quoi je
m'attacherai avec notamment des moyens
qu'ils correspondent et je ne doute pas
après avoir entendu monsieur carrère
qu'il n'hésitera pas à voter les
suppléments budgétaire que j'aurais pu
atteindre
il est un peu tard pour parler monsieur
antoine est de l'amérique latine
j'y attache une très grande importance
je crois que c'est un continent que nous
avons trop ignorée depuis des décennies
et des décennies et qui présentent de
grandes possibilités avec lequel donc
nous devons travailler
voilà monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
madame la présidente je crois que j'ai
respecté les horaires que vous m'aviez
confié ce que je veux simplement vous
dire c'est que face aux enjeux de la
mondialisation
l'unité de la nation française demeure
notre premier atout les questions de
politique étrangère mérite une approche
sereine constructif dictée par le seul
intérêt général
au delà même des intérêts partisans
cette exigence
c est la vôtre au delà des cas de
figures imposées je dirais sur le plan
politique
en tous les cas sachez que c'est la
mienne parce que c'est aussi celle de
tous ceux qui croient et qui travaille à
la grandeur de la france
merci madame le ministre un merci
d'abord parfaitement respecté le temps
qui vous était imparti
oui alors vous venez de suivre donc la
déclaration de michèle alliot marie la
ministre comme ce matin devant les
députés est revenu cet après midi sur
devant les sénateurs sur ses propos qui
ont suscité la polémique à mes côtés
pour prolonger cette discussion jean
louis carrère sénateur socialiste des
landes alors michèle alliot marie a
expliqué que ses propos avaient été
déformés elle a dit qu'elle avait été
scandalisé par les attaques
est ce qu'elle vous a convaincu non vous
savez en basque
cette façon de s'exprimer ça s'appelle
un béthio ça veut dire qu'elle a fait en
louper quoi elle a fait en louper elle
l'a reconnu plus ou moins elle essaie de
s'en défendre bon prenons acte mais
c'est regrettable parce que ça a montré
au peuple tunisien que le gouvernement
français dans la période n'avait qu'à me
proposer des forces de l'ordre et leur
savoir faire
alors qu'il attendait un petit peu autre
chose de la france alors là vous vous
avez également est indiquée à michèle
alliot marie que vous aviez indiqué par
votre collègue monique cerisier ben
guiga plusieurs reprises de la situation
en tunisie et pourtant le gouvernement
recule ce matin qu'il avait été pris de
court pourquoi le parlement est il tenu
à l'écart des questions politiques
étrangères se veut écouter le
gouvernement est tenu à l'écart parce
que ce n'est pas le ministre qui exerce
les prérogatives de la politique
étrangère dans notre pays c'est le
président de la république et certaines
séquences de ses conseillers dans
monsieur guéant qui confisque la
totalité de la politique extérieure de
la france
si tenté qu'il y en est une moi
d'ailleurs j'en arrive à à dire et
admettre l'idée qu'il n'ya pas de
politique étrangère
monsieur guéant est monsieur le
président de la république réagissent au
coup par coup et pour l'événement et
c'est de donner le change mais il n'y a
rien de risible d'ailleurs dans ce pays
actuellement
quand on interroge les anciens ministres
ou quand on interroge très tout
simplement des amis des peuples
concernés personne est en mesure de
décrypter une vraie volonté politique et
une orientation claire qui permettrait à
notre peuple
se rassembler autour de choix tels que
cela et c'est ce que j'ai demandé à la
ministre d'état pour qu'enfin nous
puissions avoir un débat et que le
parlement soit respectée parce que j'ai
relu la déclaration de 2006 du président
de la république qui s'est insurgé à
l'époque contre monsieur chirac est le
domaine réservé et qui visait que nous
l'homme quelle que soit sa fonction ne
devait considérer qu'il existait des
domaines réservés
appliquant le lui à lui et je pense que
ce sera la meilleure façon justement
pour reprendre la main sur ces questions
de politique étrangère vous souhaiter un
débat ici au sénat suivi d'un vote sur
la présence française en afghanistan
visiblement ce débat va être organisée
dans les prochains mois vous at elle
répondu oui je pense que ce débat est
nécessaire parce que depuis que
messieurs chirac président et jospin
premier ministre avait accepté l'envoi
des troupes françaises en afghanistan
il y a eu beaucoup de modifications il
ya eu les reins intégration dans le
commandement intégré de l'otan
il y a eu d envoi de troupes
supplémentaires il y a eu des micros
débat devant les assemblées mais il n'y
a jamais eu devant le sénat un vrai
débat d'orientation suivi dans vote
c'est ce que j'ai demandé cela semble
avoir été entendu mais je ne suis pas
sûr que la ministre d'état et accèder à
l'idée du vote
je crains qu'elle ne se rende compte
qu'un tel débat au sénat ferait courir
le risque à la majorité de devenir
minoritaire et donc je note sa prudence
je le regrette très bien merci à jean
louis carrère d'avoir répondu aux
questions de public sénat
maintenant je vais accueillir un autre
sénateur sénateur ump de lozère jacques
blanc donc qui me rejoint en direct sur
public sénat merci d'avoir répondu à
notre invitation alors on vient
d'entendre michèle alliot marie elle est
revenue sur ses propos qui selon elle
ont été déformés la semaine dernière à
l'assemblée nationale vous vous parlez
d'une polémique sémantique
oui moi je crois qu'aujourd'hui l'heure
est plutôt à
affirmé la capacité des uns et des
autres quelle que soit la sensibilité de
se mobiliser pour que dans le respect de
leur capacité de décider pour eux bien
sûr mais nous manifestions notre volonté
vis-à-vis du peuple tunisien de voir
cette évolution avec des chances pour la
jeunesse
la france n'a pas à s'immiscer mais la
france est qu'à porter président de la
république à porter l'ambition pour
l'euro méditerranée
eh bien on peut mesurer combien c'est
important car chacun sait bien qui a des
problèmes politiques mais qui a aussi
promu économique et que cette jeunesse
qui a été bien formé de pouvoir avoir
des perspectives et moi je suis de ceux
qui pensent très très fort que dans
cette formidable ambition euro
méditerranéenne il y a une capacité de
permettre à chacun des pays d'aller de
l'avant à la fois sur un plan économique
social et politique et donc faisons
taire toutes nos divergences et
d'ailleurs j'ai participé la semaine
dernière de 13 à la réunion du groupe
france tunisie et nous avons adopté une
résolution commune
reprenant d'ailleurs ce que le président
larcher et dès le 12 la veille donc de
notre réunion avait dit condamnant la
répression
telle qu'elle s'est faite en tunisie
avec vraiment les drames humains que
l'on mesure emma et traduisant une
volonté de voir ce pays pour voir
émerger à la fois à la vraie démocratie
et d'autre part au développement
une dernière question donc c'était
gérard longuet aussi qui a appelé
l'organisation d'élections qui a proposé
l'aide pour organiser des élections
comment c'est possible sans interférer
dans les affaires internes à la team 6
eh bien ça ça dépend de ce que valent
les tunisiens justement les groupes
d'amitié les échanges et des
partenariats existent et à partir de là
on peut en effet apporté une soutien aux
initiatives pour que ces élections qui
seront essentiels se déroule dans le
cadre du respect de la transparence les
cas de puisse permettre à la tunisie de
franchir une étape définitive vers une
démocratie et qu'elle puisse démontrer
que sur cette rive de la méditerranée
il peut y avoir la conjugaison du
respect des droits de l'homme et du
développement
je crois que c'est la meilleure réponse
qu'on puisse avoir et je me réjouis que
le président longuet pris cette
initiative
je dois dire que j'ai souligné tout à
l'heure dans mon intervention ici aussi
l'importance des coopérations sous
étatique je suis au comité des régions
d'europe on a monté une assemblée des
régions et collectivités locales pour la
méditerranée je pense que là ya aussi
une capacité des changes il ya le rôle
de l'état et a le rôle du sénat
si jacques blanche parce que nous aurons
l'occasion d'en reparler
car nous devons tout de suite retrouvé
les questions cribles thématiques y sont
consacrés aujourd'hui à l'outre-mer et à
l'europe
donc nous retournons dans l'hémicycle à
très bonne séance à tous de la politique
de cohésion
à ce titre la réunion a bénéficié pour
la période 2006 2013
de près de 2 milliards d'euros des
inquiétudes existent pour leur maintien
c'est aussi le marché communautaire du
sud